a special man is here coached on to hit
movies with Diana Ross and Lady Sings
the Blues in mahogany here is Billy Dee
Williams
gilli not only were you great in those
pictures but I gotta tell you how much I
admired you in Brian's song boy you
really moved in that picture
wait a minute I saw you in that disco
scene you did in your last special yeah
well that wasn't real me that was my
clone that was the real you of Dancing
with Cagney in the seven little fours
wasn't it you stay up that way you carry
on I'll go check my star on Hollywood
Boulevard there's a unique new camera
stabilizing system called Steadicam and
this is what what it looks like what it
does is provide total mobility and
portability in handheld photography
giving a stable jitter free image the
Academy Board of Governors has therefore
voted a special scientific and technical
award for the invention and development
of Steadicam the award goes to Garrett
Brown and a cinema products corporation
it's president idi the jig
and the engineering staff under the
supervision of John's Jergens
vice-president engineering
I'd like to thank Jack Hauser and the
people that helped from way back in the
beginning of this project and I'd like
to thank my friends here for a terrific
job in the design of the manufactured
article you just saw go by thank you I
want to thank Garrett for bringing the
invention to us and to John and the
terrific staff at cinema products for
making this dream a reality thank you
I'd like to thank the Academy and Giulio
and the people at cinema products my
friend Garrett
anymore those group acceptance speeches
this is gonna long run long run longer
than roots I want to tell you that